Fans of the Fast and Furious franchise
will no doubt be very familiar with the
ongoing feud between Vin
Diesel and Dwayne Johnson.
The Rock entered the series in Fast Five as
Luke Hobbs, a DSS bounty hunter tasked with
tracking down Diesel's character,
Dominic Toretto, and his allies.
"I don't have friends. I got family."
Hobbs and Dom go from enemies to
frenemies by the end of the movie,
and Johnson would go on to appear in
three more films in the main franchise.
But things apparently weren't
always rosy behind the scenes.
While the eighth film was shooting in 2016,
Johnson took to his Instagram to spill the
tea regarding some previous on-set drama. The
actor praised his female co-stars but mentioned
the men were, in his words, "a different story."
While Johnson didn't specifically name the acting
partners who caused him problems, it was clear
enough that Diesel was the issue. Johnson wrote:
"Some conduct themselves as stand up men
and true professionals, while others don't.
The ones that don't are too chicken
s--t to do anything about it anyway."
Since then, the two actors' feud
has been a non-stop back and forth.
Johnson was the last to mention it during
an interview with THR in July, in which he
wished the franchise well — and confirmed
he wouldn't appear in any more Fast films.
"I'll see you soon."
"...No you won't."
However, it seems like Diesel is
bringing up their rivalry yet again,
albeit in a totally surprising way. In
an Instagram post shared on November 7th,
Diesel offered the olive branch of all olive
branches to his former co-star. He wrote:
"My little brother Dwayne... the time has
come. The world awaits the finale of Fast 10.
As you know, my children refer to you as Uncle
Dwayne in my house. There is not a holiday
that goes by that they and you don't send well
wishes... but the time has come. Legacy awaits."
Of course, not only is Fast 10 on its way, but so
is Fast 11, with both films serving as a two-part
epic finale for the long-running series. Referring
to the late Paul Walker, Diesel continued:
"I told you years ago that I was
going to fulfill my promise to Pablo.
I swore that we would reach and manifest
the best Fast in the finale that is 10!
I say this out of love... but you must
show up [...] Hobbs can't be played by
no other. I hope that you rise to the
occasion and fulfill your destiny."
So it looks like Diesel is happy
to let bygones be bygones for the
sake of the Fast franchise. But
will Johnson feel the same way?
Well, right now Johnson has yet to respond to
his former co-star's plea for reconciliation.
But considering how active he is on social media,
you can probably expect to hear something soon.
It's worth noting that, even before his new
Instagram post, Diesel appeared to be over
their feud. In a June interview with Men's
Health, the actor claimed his issues with
Johnson came from pushing his co-star to the
limit to get the best performance. He said:
"That took a lot of work. We
had to get there, and sometimes,
at that time, I could give a lot
of tough love. Not Felliniesque,
but I would do anything I'd have to do in order
to get performances in anything I'm producing."
Nevertheless, it's probably going to take a
lot more than an Instagram plea to get Dwayne
Johnson signed on to Fast 10 and 11. And there's
no way to know if Vin Diesel has reached out to
Johnson in private, or whether the social media
strategy is currently his only plan of action.
Unsurprisingly, if the Fast and the Furious
fandom had anything to say about it,
Johnson would have signed on the dotted line right
away. Diesel's Instagram post was liked well over
a half a million times and had 10,000 comments
just a mere two hours after it was posted.
In the past, fans seemed to have
taken Johnson's side in the feud,
but for the sake of Fast 10, it looks
like everyone is on the side of family.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.